For the rest of the course, we're only
going to be using these letters over here,
which are the symbols of the DNA code.
But never forget that what we're actually working with
here is chemistry, because chemistry is the heart
of this biology, one really useful phrase to remember
as we continue in this course is that
structure is Function. And, what we mean by that,
is if we change one letter, or one nitrogenous base pair, then that means the
structure, the chemical structure, has changed at
that nitrogenous base pair. So, although you just
see a letter difference, the chemistry has
changed. And in the chemical world, molecules interact
based on whether their structures let them. If
the structure changes, then so can the function.
In reality, other molecules are actually able
to come and interact with the chemistry
of the DNA here. We consider that reading the base pairs. So even though
we're just symbolizing them with letters, the
molecular chemistry is actually interacting. So if
a letter in the DNA changes then the structure changes and there's going to be a
change in what other molecules can interact and the overall function can change.